I told you I'm in content mode baby I'm
writing and I'm I got some gems uh I'll
give you the headline of something I'm
writing right now I haven't even
released this any of this stuff yet
um but but it's called congratulations
you climbed Mount stupid
[Music]
what's up fellas it's Friday how you
guys doing
doing great good good uh we're reacting
to the news we got some good ones this
week uh let's start with uh let's start
with Jake Paul vs Tommy Fury uh Jake
Paul of course the famous influencer uh
has since become a professional boxer
for the first time he lost a fight uh
losing to uh Tommy Fury a professional
boxer and social media influencer and uh
not just the fight is notable but what's
also notable is that Sam you basically
called exactly what would happen in the
fight uh so do you want to take your
Victory lap right now Sam no I didn't
call exactly but I have been getting
good at predicting fights I'm a huge
Combat Sports Fan
um but I I didn't exactly get it but I
loved it you know I know why I love it I
love freak shows this was a freak Show
and I am always going to pay for that
pay-per-view and watch freak shows I
thought it was awesome second I think if
you're listening to this whether you're
a man or a woman you should go and train
boxing just for like three months and
actually Spar not like Rumble where
you're just hitting the bag but I think
you should Spar and I'm not talking Spar
like when you kick someone's ass or you
get beat up because Sean you remember
when we spared it doesn't hurt right if
you do it with someone who like it
doesn't have to hurt but well you know
what it does it scares you it's a very
get the heart rate up it gets the heart
rate up it you if you do it right with
someone who's been there done that
you're not gonna get hurt I promise
you're gonna get hurt by running more
than you will actually sparring if you
do it with someone who knows what
they're doing but that like fight or
flight response we never get that and so
I love that he did that I find it very
courageous that he actually stood in
front of all these people and fought so
kudos to him but uh
yeah I don't think he's gonna like be a
great boxer I mean probably him uh first
of all came on the show so Gotta Give
him credit for that came on came on our
show now he's doing other shows these
are all you know just the highlights of
his life I'm sure it's just a
correlation yeah they exactly I'm not
saying one cause the other but like
probably we did do our show before you
know a lot of this stuff happened we we
did do our show before he did every
other show and so uh I thought it was
great you know uh I think the transition
from like Disney kid vine star YouTuber
kind of [__] uh you know brand to
he's legitimately good he is
legitimately good he is not I would not
call him a celebrity boxer he's like an
amateur boxer actually like he's like
he's a very good amateur very good
amateur boxer and he's an Entertainer
and like he you know he's done an
amazing job staying relevant but
evolving the game with him I think that
uh a lot of people hate on this guy or
laugh at him or whatever else I think
there's a lot of good lessons you can
take about Reinventing yourself and
finding a way to merge maybe things
you're interested in or passionate about
with your skills in the world of
business or entertainment and uh he's
done it phenomenally well and thinking
from first principles like him and his
brother Logan
they didn't just ask what should I do
next as a YouTuber they were like what
can I do next using this audience in
this Fame and they came up with
different answers than 99.9 of other
YouTubers out there you're getting
credit for that
yeah and he's tough I don't think he's
gonna be a great boxer but he's super
tough for doing that so that's awesome
next
from one controversial social media star
to another Andrew Tate and his brother
Tristan are being detained for a third
30-day sentence in Romania of course
they're charged with human trafficking
they claim that there is no evidence and
they still haven't had a trial uh what
you guys take Andrew take human
trafficker or wrongly imprisoned oof I
don't know much about it do you no I
mean who knows what he did but uh first
of all Romania guilty and until proven
innocent what's going on here why is he
why is he in these like he says because
he's tweeting out he says he's like in
solitary confinement basically
um while he hasn't had a trial that's a
that's a little strange he also said uh
dude he said I've been in this thing for
30 days now they don't let me out just
imagine locking yourself in your bedroom
for 24 hours just go ahead and do that
now think about where I'm going through
I wanted to cry but then he said like
but I realize I'm too tough for that uh
but it sounds like you have Twitter
access does everybody can somebody
explain this to me because he tweeted
out two hours ago my body is in jail but
my mind is not in jail do you understand
what I don't understand is how do you
have Twitter right now yeah I don't know
either what kind of LAX prison is this
yeah and you said are you gonna be
putting free Tate in your Twitter bio no
I'm not going to be putting that I I
don't care
dude I will pay you 100 to put free
Cobra tape in your Twitter bio that
would be so funny for 24 hours just do
it that'd be amazing oh no not a chance
I I'm not team Andrew Tate I wouldn't
say I'm not I don't like how he talks to
people so I guess I would say I'm I'm
kind of against them I have no idea
about the story other than if he did do
what he's accused of then yeah that
sounds pretty fair but I have no idea
what the truth is
yeah he's kind of cringe to be honest
with you but uh yeah let's go on all
right let's move on to the lab leak
Theory so multiple government sources
are now saying that they think the lab
leak theory for the origins of kova 19
is true this includes the department of
energy and the FBI so fellas are you
surprised I am not surprised I am not
surprised this ever since that one Jon
Stewart clip have you seen this this Jon
Stewart clip Sam where he goes he was
ringing the bell early on right yeah it
was pretty early on this was like when
it was still
unpopular and in fact you would get like
seven kids bigger your videos taken down
or like a giant flag saying this
person's a conspiracy theorist for
saying it and he goes on the Colbert's
show and he does this little bit where
he goes
um he says something about the lab leak
and you know this leak from a lab and
it's crazy and then Colbert goes we you
know gladly I mean you're saying that we
there we don't know that there's no
evidence because evidence
there's a coronavirus that originated in
Wuhan
where there is the wuhad coronavirus lab
because it's in the name and he just
keeps going off he's like he's like
there's a chocolate leak in Hershey
Pennsylvania is this you know is this
random or maybe it's the Chocolate
Factory you know like he brings us up
and it was just like so obvious at that
point uh and it's like what how unlikely
would it be that in all places the novel
he's like the novel coronavirus
originates in Wuhan where there is the
Wuhan novel coronavirus research lab
like that you know you're telling me
that that just happened to be the case
like seems like the odds are that it
came from that lab not that it just
happened to be in that land in that same
area I remember my friend Jack telling
me about this like early on and my
friend jack is not quite a he's not a
conspiracy theorist at all but he is
very open-minded and like he believes
like he doesn't believe lots of things
but he'll like when people say that they
originally were thinking well that's
crazy and his response was like okay
well let's see what the evidence is and
and maybe we'll explore it and I
remember him telling me that I'm like
Jack you're pretty crazy for thinking
that and my big lesson over these last
three years as it regards to this story
is not like did it or did it not come
out of that but now it's looking like
maybe it did or at least for sure it did
somewhere between maybe and for sure not
for sure it didn't and my takeaway is
there's things that I would use to
dismiss as just crazy and only crazy
people would believe this but I've seen
over the last five or ten years as I've
like become more of an adult and like
paid attention to these things I've seen
that like
man crazy things do happen and also a
lot of huge life-changing things are
just accidents they just happen like and
and now I have a little bit more of an
open mind when people say like well this
person is uh conspiring with this other
person to make this happen or whatever
and I'm like oh baby they're let's let's
have an open mind and explore the facts
if we can right yeah there's a I
remember back when this first started it
was basically considered racist to say
that the virus might have leached from
the lab in China
and I never understood that I was like
why would that be racist how is that
racist I lived in China I don't find
This Racist in any way like what are you
talking about and um it reminds me of
one time I tweeted out my favorite books
I've tweeted out five of my favorite
books or something like that and then
the comment goes a bunch of people start
commenting they go there's not one woman
on this list
these are my favorite books what are you
talking about what are you talking about
what I have to have 50 diversity in my
favorite books and I I just replied I go
all my favorite NBA players are black
and I just sent people off that that
totally triggered everybody because I
was like no I am not apologizing because
I named five of my favorite books and
they just so happen to be written by men
like that is not at all what I'm talking
about and you're trying to like you know
I call these people meter maids they
just run around the internet looking for
little tickets at the cars that they
could ticket like where can I go be
offended
um you did you didn't you were not
inclusive enough for me take it and I
was like what are you talking about
that's not even what this was about did
you invent meter maid yeah yeah I did
that last night I told you about content
mode baby I'm writing and I'm I got some
gems uh I'll give you the headline of
something I'm writing right now I
haven't even released any of this stuff
yet
um but but it's called congratulations
you climbed Mount stupid
I don't know
the course from that headline to be like
what's the what is the content here uh
but I've just got a bunch of jams that
I'm putting uh in my on my email list by
the way go go subscribe to my email list
I'll put in the show notes seanbury.com
and go go put your thing in there I'm
writing 365 original pieces in the next
uh in the next year so one a day will go
out and one of them is gonna be called
congratulations you climbed Mount stupid
what are you doing like a daily email
yeah but it's a sequence
that would never work it'll work I know
I'm joking because we both had okay
our software is the worst have you heard
of HubSpot see most crms are a cobble
together mess but HubSpot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better all right
Ben what do you got all right let's go
rapid fire through a few of these uh I
don't know if you saw this the Felix
Dennis house so Felix Dennis very famous
entrepreneur your boy I love him yeah uh
publisher of Oz and author of how to be
rich so he built this house for five
million pounds uh it just sold for four
million pounds it's really cool but one
of the weirdest houses you'll ever see
it's mostly a pool uh in the middle and
it's a Treasure Island themed with like
palm trees and like a bunch of pirate
stuff and the whole house only has two
bedrooms so the question is fellas
does this make you guys into themed
houses are you guys going to be building
uh themed houses now well the takeaway
here for me is f Legacy it's because
this guy built something that he wanted
and oftentimes people will say things
like um well what about the resale value
of this thing
um or how how is this going to impact
your legacy and my reply to that lately
has been like well I don't know like I'm
I'm gonna be dead I don't care and so
what I appreciate about this is that he
spent his money the way he wanted to and
he made something cool even if it didn't
do uh make any Financial sense so I
think it's cool
um and if you haven't read his book how
to get rich we've talked about a bunch
here it changed my life whenever we talk
about that book it like goes up to like
number uh 10 top 10 in the business
category so go read it it's awesome
there's a picture in this article of him
with a
extremely voluptuous person that says
Felix Dennis spent a hundred million
dollars on sex drugs and rock and roll
in his lifetime
yeah that's what he talks about so he
basically says
right Sam yeah
was that your new company's mission
statement
core values
close uh he uh basically from age like
35 to uh like 40. he was addicted to
crack that was his drug was I swear to
God crack cocaine he loved it and he
died uh single he had a partner but they
had an open relationship so the guy's
been doing a lot of psychedelics and
open relationships before it was cool
um no he was a very weird and quirky guy
and he like basically says he spent
north of 100 million dollars in his book
he goes I spent 100 100 million on on
hookers and crack so uh you know
whatever dude yeah I don't believe that
everyone's talking Wilt Chamberlain said
he slept with 10 000 women in his
lifetime and if you do the math do the
math on that is like horrible it's like
it's crazy it's like dude you gotta
sleep with two women a day for you know
many years yeah I think it's even more
than that yeah because he wasn't that
old at that time
um by the way you said something about
themed houses I'm in on themed houses I
think themed houses are great and more
than more than the theme actually is
epic common area he said two bedrooms
that I think bedrooms are a giant waste
I think you only need a couple bedrooms
and you should have epic common areas if
you're gonna have a mansion I don't like
the eight bedroom mansion you know like
I got opinions on mansions and that's
one of them you gotta have epic common
spaces and only a couple bedrooms three
four bedrooms Max I don't want to see a
fifth bedroom and you know what his um
charity was that he left all this money
to was creating forests so he's like the
Johnny Appleseed of England the guy he
like has like thousands of Acres of
forests that he owns and I think this
house it's known for having all types of
trees so in Colombia he's like the crack
cocaine Foundation
donating my wealth
all right all right I love this one the
Minnesota Department of Transportation
ran a snowplow naming contest so they
got a new snow plow they needed a name
and they out they crowdsource it to the
public here's some of the top vote
Getters you're a blizzard Harry blizzo
clearopathra better call salt and Han
Solo so guys do you have a favorite from
this list
their last one I think I like clear
clearopatha I think that one's pretty
good I did not see that one coming
remember when they did a Bodie mcboat
face when like uh I think it was like uh
I think it was like either a fairy or a
tugboat or something like that like a
town let people vote on it and Reddit
got a hold of it and they made the
number one voted thing boaty mcboatface
uh and so I love these viral stunts I
think they're awesome well Sam I don't
want to steal your thunder but you did
want to announce your tattoo naming
contest Sam is willing to get a tattoo
on his back that any anybody that is
gonna be a contest from the fans of my
first million isn't that right Sam
that is we're totally wrong I was I
think I did when I did say there's this
you remember how we talked about mini
Katana yeah
they're sending me a gold sword I guess
Katana I don't know the difference that
has MFM on it so I've I'm collecting all
types of MFM stuff I don't know Katana a
sword by the way is it
what reader made the meter maids are
running around they're excited about
that one
uh well I have a gold Katana on my way
that has my first million on it so I'll
I'll accept all MFM stuff but I'm not
gonna tattoo with these okay how about a
million YouTube subscribers will you get
a crowdsourced tattoo I will get a
tattoo at a million for sure uh when I I
went and did this podcast uh in LA with
like this guy Cody KO so he's really
good he's kind of like a a comedy
YouTuber guy and um his Studio looked
awesome he was telling us about they
have this uh they have like a network
and they have some other show called
trillionaire energy or something like
that
um and so he they put it up on the
screen there's like a screen you can see
while we're sitting there and it was The
Two Hosts in slow motion with music just
getting closer together and these two
guys just made out and I'll go whoa
what's the show about and he goes no
they had said if they get to whatever a
hundred thousand Subs that they would
kiss did they really do that and I go oh
yeah that's a good idea that's how like
you comedy YouTuber Hollywood people
think yeah that's a good idea We're not
gonna do that but but that's a great do
they really do it like they did it it's
a hilarious video it's in slow-mo as
they get closer and closer and they just
make out are they tongued it's intense
I'd rather be I'd rather be unsuccessful
yeah exactly
[Music]
how bad you want it I don't want it that
bad this incredible success you gotta
find the price of success and then pay
it it's too expensive for me yeah it's
out of my budget yeah I'm out we have we
have food at home
you wanna do one more yeah that's the
last one all right last one so uh blue
sky is a new Twitter clone uh backed by
Jack Dorsey and unlike Twitter it is
decentralized and so the question is
fellas are you supporting our comrades
over at Blue Sky or are you supporting
the capitalist pigs over at Twitter
what's your move dude Jack Dorsey owns a
bank how are you gonna call him a
comrade right I mean he's moving away
from Capital he's seen the air of his
way soon dude when I hear okay so here's
some of the words they use open source
social protocol uh and decentralized
when I hear those words I just I just
don't care I just don't care at all like
they want me to care about it and that's
wonderful and maybe sometimes I'll act
like I do uh but I don't I don't care at
all uh like if you tell me uh
probiotic
antioxidant right yeah I don't care if
you want to shove it in there and I'll
I'll drink it if it tastes good right
but I don't but I don't even know I'll
drink it if it tastes it that's my take
on this as well I'll use this this app
if it's awesome if the content is great
the people on it are interesting and if
it's something different than Twitter if
it's Twitter but the database is
different I'm out I don't care about
that that's not that's not what draws
people in I don't that doesn't mean it's
not a good idea great do it do it
differently under the hood but it has to
result in something different that the
person actually gets to use
yeah and the same thing happened with
web3 where they like
they give me this horrible pitch and
then they end it with web3 and I'm like
well I don't care if it's web3 just does
this thing work is it awesome and I feel
the same way about this so I don't care
and also Matt have you tried Mastodon
yeah
dude it's stupid too it's stupid no like
it's it's dumb so anyway I'm not on
board with this all right all right
[Music]
foreign